big little lies there have been two
seasons now yeah
and fantastic experience for you mean
one of the greatest casts assembled and
you've been killing it question would
there be another season well you know
how could this keep going right this can
this keep couldn't they keep this story
going I mean there are some people that
thought well how could you have a season
two and then they did and it's been very
popular so what do you felt little
candle I've be yeah yeah season eight if
they are going to be microscopic they
turn into tiny little insignificant life
entire ways did you have some of the
almond butter no little super boring
lives
yeah yeah everyone's on on the floor
looking for the lies because they're so
I don't know I think that you know
getting all of everyone's schedules
lined up for season two was a gargantuan
task it would be really fun but I have
no idea if there took these massive
stars yeah you got to get them I mean
literally no pun intended you have to
get them to align uh no I really wasn't
I just know I mentioned you have to get
you have to get all these people that
you know could control countries yeah to
to to have the same schedule at the same
time huge enormous ly powerful
superstars yeah and I don't know how
they did it but they did it twice so you
know